okay a Donald Trump had a completely
propagandistic 1984 style Town Hall
yesterday he took questions from
Americans via video while sitting at the
Lincoln Memorial yesterday we believed
that it was Donald Trump who had
selected the Lincoln Memorial as the
location but then during this event
Donald Trump said oh no you guys told
you thought you guys being Fox News you
guys told us you wanted it at the
Lincoln Memorial the two fox hosts bret
bayer and martha maccallum visibly
confused about wait a second I thought
we were here because you wanted us here
doesn't even matter that's only the tip
of the iceberg my friends because it was
an absolute and complete nightmare now
because we're doing fewer and fewer of
the briefings I do think it's important
to bring you a sense of what the
president is communicating and in
relation to our segment earlier today on
whether the United States is a failed
state of sorts last night's Town Hall
was more than illuminating in that sense
now first of all Donald Trump came in
absolutely shot out of a cannon like he
was on some kind of upper and we've
talked about this before Trump visibly
very sweaty sniffing repeating himself
more than usual clenching his jaw unable
to sit still and you know we know about
these two versions of Trump you've got
upper Trump and then you've got downer
Trump as I like to call them something
very strange seems to continue with
Donald Trump along those lines it's
tough to analyze and we may never know
the full scope of that let's put the
sort of appearance aside and focus on
the content what we can more easily
analyze was the absolutely debased and
abominable things that Donald Trump said
along with the complete and total lack
of truth in almost every single answer
that Donald Trump gave it would be hard
to do a more dishonest townhall
he also barely answered any of the
questions in anything what we would call
direct sense but as we go through this I
want to frame it for you upfront his
supporters loved it his supporters loved
it before we go into the clips
understand that however you see Donald
Trump as
hopefully rational sensible thinking
person who watches or listens to the
David Pakman show what you see in these
upcoming clips his followers loved and
saw as strong Trump unwilling to be
bullied and pushed around competent
Trump dealing with everything perfectly
that's a really scary reality that we
have to come to terms with let's get
into it Donald Trump often mentions the
1918 flu he often calls it the 1917 flu
this was a pandemic from about a hundred
years ago it was late 1918 through early
summer of 1919 it affected infected
rather it's believed about 500 million
the death rate could have been the death
toll could have been anywhere from 17
million you hear 50 million you
sometimes hear a hundred million based
on the numbers you look at Trump wildly
claims without evidence that the 1917
flu ended World War one prematurely
check this out right you remember the
Spanish flu I've so much has been
written about it now of course it's
taught us everybody that writes a book
about the Spanish from 1917 it killed
between a hundred and I guess fifty to a
hundred million people it probably ended
the first world war because the soldiers
were all getting sick now this is not
true it's simply not true the war sort
of formally ended with the Treaty of
Versailles in June of 1919 but fighting
had mostly died down seven months prior
to that there's no question that there
were service members around the world
infected with the flu but this is a
crazy thing for Donald Trump to say no
pushback whatsoever from martha
maccallum and brett bayer not to defend
them but almost everything Trump said on
this issue was false so there was a sort
of Gish Gallup effect going on look that
term up if you're not familiar with it
Trump was asked a question about how he
was supposedly getting intelligence on
the virus really early and he ignored it
and Donald Trump claimed that he wasn't
told that the virus might be a thing
until January 23rd I'm gonna play the
clip for you now remember we had our
first case on January 20th that we know
of we now know it
is obviously far earlier because of when
the first death happened but there are
two options here when Trump says he was
first told this could be a thing on
January turning 23rd neither is good
I'll tell them to you after we watch the
clip because I did the right thing I
saved hundreds of thousands of lives
okay
she's asking me the question about
intelligence I have the head of the
intelligence agencies here today and
here's the exact thing and we have it
it's going to be released tomorrow the
next day but I released it today on
January 23rd I was told that there could
be a virus coming in but it was of no
real import in other words it wasn't all
we got to do something we got to do
something so understand Trump says he
was told January 23 the virus might come
in we had our first case three days
earlier okay we had our first case on
January 20th South Korea had its first
case right around the same time as we
did within hours of our first case they
by January 23rd were already developing
a test and setting up ways to contact
trace and isolate people and Trump is
now claiming he was first told this
could be coming in three days after the
first case now there's two options here
one is Trump is just lying and I believe
Trump is lying now his met his brain may
have turned to mayonnaise and he may not
recall that he was being briefed about
this in early January there are reports
about briefings in December there are
now some reports which we have not yet
fully corroborated that suggests in late
November this was already being
discussed so Trump could just be lying
and saying I didn't even really hear
about this as a serious thing until
three days after the first case that is
probably a lie if it's true it's
outrageous that Trump was not seriously
warned until three days after the first
case it goes against every bit of
reporting we have I believe Trump is
lying or has completely lost his memory
neither is good continuing with this
disgusting townhall Donald Trump claims
that he has been treated that he he has
been treated worse than Abraham Lincoln
and hilariously the person asking the
question actually said why
do you sometimes ramble without asking
questions that are asked of you
by the press here is that part of Donald
Trump's answer the question I have is
about your manner of presentation why do
you use descriptive words that could be
classified as bullying and why do not
directly answer the questions asked by
the press but instead speak of past
successes and general ramble the US I
need you please let go of those
behaviors that are turning people away
from you
please hold onto your wonderful
attributes that make you our great
leader and let go of other
characteristics that do not serve you
wait I think I like that question I'm
not sure but I think I like that
question I appreciate it I appreciate
the prayers too very much look I am
greeted with a hostile press the likes
of which no president has ever seen the
closest would be that gentleman right up
there they always said Lincoln nobody
got treated worse than Lincoln I believe
I am treated worse
now of course Abraham Lincoln was
assassinated
okay Trump is talking about being
treated worse by the press than Lincoln
but again
Trump's delusions delusions of grandeur
treated worse than anyone including
Lincoln because sometimes the press asks
real questions and he never answers them
and they have to ask again now on the
death toll this is really important and
it's actually tragic Donald Trump is
very casually moving the goal posts for
close to a month Donald Trump has been
saying we're gonna have 60,000 deaths
thanks to me could have had 1.5 million
we could have had two point two million
but thanks to me our death toll is going
to be only 60,000 that ship has sailed
we now are already at almost 70,000
deaths in the United States so Trump has
very smoothly talked about listen we
could lose 80 or 90 thousand and that
would be terrible
moving the goal posts take a look that's
one of the reasons we're successful
that's one of the review call losing
eighty or ninety thousand people
successful but it's one of the reasons
that we're not at that high end of the
plane as opposed to the low end of that
number has changed mr. president you
said it's going up I used to say 65,000
and now I'm saying eighty or ninety and
it goes up and it goes up
rapidly but it's still going to be no
matter how you look at it at the very
lower end of the plane if we did be shut
down now this was always the plan say
some insanely high number that would
only happen if he literally did nothing
and then say he gets credit for it being
less understand a couple of different
things this 1.5 million 2.2 million
Trump for the first time now floating
2.5 million that may have been if he
literally did nothing
no president could realistically do
nothing so it's an outrageous bar to set
to even compare to but the real
dishonesty is that in the last 48 hours
Trump has increased his expected death
toll by 50 percent from 60,000 to 90,000
and the way things are going it could
easily be a hundred thousand before we
know it but Trump is immune from
criticism because again without him it
would have been 2 million
he's now for the first time floated 2.5
million if he did nothing that's a
higher number than he's ever mentioned
before this is mere politics for Donald
Trump it's not lives and one just
strange moment during yesterday's Town
Hall was again it was a very hopped up
Trump who seemed to be crunching and
sweating and visibly on some he was
upper Trump I don't want to say what he
was on if anything but he was upper
Trump he said that he was asked for
Schwab's Schwab's by a governor this is
just too funny
we had one Governor Inslee who's always
wanting something and frankly he didn't
do a very good job when nursing homes as
far as I'm concerned state of Washington
and he said we need Schwab's I said why
don't you get him yourself but if you
can't we'll get him so ok swaps a
totally lie riddled propaganda event a
few other notes Donald Trump said Joe
Biden wrote him a letter of apology
that's just not true
Trump once again started talking about
hydroxychloroquine and told multiple
lies about its efficacy and Trump
continues to say that China is paying
for tariffs I want to take a moment just
to explain that I need everybody in my
RT
to understand this and I think most of
you do Trump still doesn't understand
how tariffs work Trump continues to
insist we're punishing China by putting
tariffs on them which they are paying us
and sometimes he says it's like a tax on
China please understand that American
companies play the terror hey the
tariffs I know I've said this before I
have to keep repeating it because Trump
seems to still not understand if China
sells steel for a thousand bucks a rod
okay doesn't matter whatever amount a
thousand bucks a ton and we put a tariff
on China China still sells that steel
for a thousand bucks a ton but if
there's a fifteen percent tariff on it
when an American company buys it the
American company pays China they're a
thousand bucks and they pay the
government a hundred and fifty more
dollars American companies pay the
tariffs now if you believe that
this trade war would work China could be
forced to lower their price and accept
the lower price because of the tariffs
that American companies are paying it's
not happening it's not happening Trump
still doesn't understand how tariffs
work we are seeing the active and
willful dissemination of weaponized
propaganda but the saddest thing is that
his followers love it and they see this
as a strong performance we have one
option and it's to remove Trump in
November I hope you'll help me do that
I'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep I sleep on
a helix mattress at home I absolutely
love it and that's why I reached out to
them about sponsoring the David Pakman
show buying a mattress in the past was
always a huge guessing game for me I
didn't know what I actually needed I
didn't know what I would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years
by both GQ and Wired magazine it is
well-deserved I can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty you can try the mattress
risk-free for 100 nights and they will
even come pick it up at your house if
you don't love it but I know you will
all of my viewers will get up to $200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free when you go to
the link right underneath this video